[inaudible]
travel tips, let's talk about them.
I've traveled to a lot of places,
especially in the last 10 years,
something like 40 plus countries and I
have learned a lot about what works for
me at least.
So I'll share a few of them.
Number one for earplugs the
best I have found Max and AC,
k apostrophe, s silicone
earplugs. These are not foam.
You don't roll them up and
stick them in your ear.
You actually affectively
plastered them over the year.
And I was introduced to these
by competitive swimmers.
But what's really nice about these ae,
they block more sound at least as
far as I can perceive. Secondly,
you can sleep on your side
or something like that.
They do not come out and they do not
poke further into your ear. So I'm a big,
big fan of these earplugs and I have them
in every bag that I might travel with.
So I redundancy there.
Next is a ball rub at the SPEC.
Looks like a golf ball with tiny
little points on it. Are you be z?
And this is for rolling out
your feet before you travel.
And when you land and let's say you get
to a hotel, airbnb, whatever it might be,
first thing take off the shoes were all
at your feet and this tends to prevent
and alleviate a lot of tension,
not only in the legs and hips but also
in the back for whatever reason. Uh,
tip pro tip, if you have
the option, get a massage,
say the date after you land,
not the day you land.
For reasons we won't get into
right now and focus on cervical,
neck and upper spine and that can also
dramatically reduce or remove any type of
back soreness and so on that was
incurred through travel. Next tip,
I always have two particular items for
immune function or supporting in the and
function.
I have sprayable,
zinc and there are many
different types that you can use,
which I'll use probably three
or four times on days of travel.
Also I will travel with one gram capsules
or tablets of vitamin C and while I am
traveling,
I'll take one gram every hour that
I'm awake and that there's a lot.
So used to a gut tolerance
as they would say.
In other words, don't make yourself
a poo in your pants. Disaster Pants,
no Bueno. So you might want to test
that before you're on an airplane.
And then last,
this is perhaps the the a coup de Gras,
one of my favorite discoveries in the
last five or six years and it is travel
caching. What does caching mean?
That is from cash, not cash money,
but see a c h e,
right?
And this means that for the
locations I visit most often,
if you look at travel patterns, let's
just say for me within the United States,
very often I'm flying to the same places.
Maybe 80 90% of the time.
New York City, let's say
Miami, whatever it might be,
I will develop a relationship
with a particular hotel.
All of these hotels have.
Then what I will do is for the
weather in that particular city,
I will have seven to 10 days worth
of clothing, including any type of,
say outerwear for New York City.
In the winter one jacket,
we'll do one or two pairs of shoes,
say sneakers for walking,
and then something that equates to
business casual or for something a little
more fancy and it lives in New York City.
It stays there all the time. How does this
work? Well, I can walk to the airport,
use a clear card,
which I use for everything and I,
I became an advisor to the company
after many years of using it,
which will get me from walking in
the door of the airport to the gate.
Usually in say six or seven minutes.
It's incredibly effective
for skipping security lines,
clear card, and then
I walk in, no luggage,
maybe a backpack with a laptop
and that's it. I land in New York.
I've everything that I need.
Then at the end of the trip,
I'll also even include say some coconut
oil or almond butter and a sardines and
cans that's picked up from
Dominic D'Agostino. Scientist.
So I have even food,
if I write,
if I arrived late at night or simply
don't want to deal with room service,
I even have some food
that's not likely to expire.
I wear this clothing for say a week and
then I pack it up or I don't pack it up.
I just leave it in the room. And because
I am a frequent visitor at the hotel,
I asked them to do wash and fold or
clean out of the hotel, pack it up,
put it back in my trunk.
So they'll often even give you a trunk
to you as you can buy one for 50 bucks.
But I was given a trunk.
It's not because they know who I am,
it's because I've developed a relationship
and it's cheap for them to help
anyway. Uh, and they will
wash, fold the clothing,
put it back in your trunk,
lock it up, put it in storage,
and then it's ready for use the next time.
It's fantastic.
And so you have that not everywhere.
Okay.
So it's maybe a few hundred bucks
that you spend and it's in one or two
locations, meaning one or two cities,
and you have everything that you need.
You do not need to pack a single thing
and it's recycled and ready for use the
next time you go there. Uh, that is
a longterm investment. Of course,
it's not for everybody, but for the
cost of one or two plane tickets,
you can never pack luggage or never have
to pack luggage again to your two most
common destinations. It's, for me,
at least, an incredibly, incredibly,
a fantastic return on investment and has
made my travel life infinitely easier
and more enjoyable.
So those are a few tips you can take and
run with good luck and happy traveling.